the next Marlon Brando the next Banksy
or Persona nangrada and for good reason
Shia LaBeouf used to be the next big
thing here's what happened next Shia
LaBeouf began his acting career in his
tween years his earliest roles were
mostly in small largely forgotten family
films in the late 90s like the Christmas
path and breakfast with Einstein he
found more success when he moved into
television with one-off appearances on
notable shows like er Freaks and Geeks
and the X-Files which one's your
favorite it used to be basketball
but now the Bulls suck so
I think maybe baseball his real
breakthrough came with his starring role
on the Disney Channel series Even
Stevens which ran for three seasons and
concluded with a movie spin-off that
sludgy machine shouldn't be sitting in
some junkyard rusting away it should be
in my room providing me with satisfying
icy beverages Around the Clock after his
Disney tenure came to an end LaBeouf
spent a little longer working in
family-friendly spaces as with his
starring vocal role in the Sony animated
film Surfs Up however it wouldn't be
much longer before LaBeouf transitioned
away from his child actor image into
darker and more serious roles as his
career developed Le buff went out of his
way to choose challenging roles at the
polar opposite end of the spectrum from
the comedic roles he was first known for
but before he went down the dark Indie
route he first landed in the Blockbuster
sphere titles like Transformers and
Indiana Jones and the kingdom of the
Crystal Skull pushed him as a new
leading man for big budget
spectacle-driven films while their
reception was often Rock key they were
typically extremely successful at the
box office his string of blockbuster
hits gave lebuff the cachet in Hollywood
to pick and choose whatever roles he
wanted
I'm ready
don't give these pigs a thing after
several years as a mainstream leading
man Le buff made a major pivot he made
the Bold decision to step away from the
highly lucrative Transformers franchise
and leave Blockbusters in general behind
from 2012 onward LaBeouf's filmography
has been solely focused on smaller
projects after some recent scandals a
couple of Duds and a handful of years
without any major titles released some
might have thought LaBeouf's acting
career was over in reality the Buff's
career is still in perfectly fine shape
even though he was fired from the recent
don't worry darling he claims he quit
his dry spell will be coming to an end
with the release of movies like
assassination and megalopolis from David
Mamet and Francis Ford Coppola
respectively more than any other
celebrity in recent memory Le buff has
become inextricably linked to the act of
plagiarism he may have begun earlier but
the first time Le buff was caught in the
act was in 2012 when a couple of his con
comic books were found to include lines
stolen from authors like Charles
Bukowski in response to being called out
he stole the apology Tiger Woods had
given after his cheating scandal after
he made a sudden departure from a
Broadway play he was performing in
alongside Alec Baldwin in 2013. his
personal apology to his co-star was
later revealed to be plagiarized from an
Esquire magazine piece titled what is a
man when confronted for stealing from
the article he responded by stealing the
words of David Mamet the Buff's acts of
plagiarism grew Bolder over time he
released a 12-minute short film titled
Howard cantore.com fans of the short
comic Justin M Damiano immediately
noticed that howardcantor.com seemed an
awful lot like a direct adaptation of
the source material the problem was that
LE buff did not acquire the rights to
the story nor did he credit the comic's
Creator Daniel Klaus despite lifting the
plot themes and dialogue wholesale unsub
surprisingly LaBeouf plagiarized his
apology to Klaus in an insincere move
that seemed to mock the idea that he had
anything to be sorry for perhaps Le
Buff's most head-turning stunt was when
he showed up on a red carpet with his
face hidden beneath a paper bag bearing
the words I am not famous anymore the
incident happened at the Berlin
International Film Festival in 2014
while Le buff was there accompanying his
performance in Lars von trier's
nymphomaniac Vol 1. he had been tweeting
the same words I am not famous anymore
over and over again for nearly a month
leading up to the event at the same Film
Festival Le buff also made a spectacle
of himself during a group press
conference with other members of the
nymphomaniac cast and crew after Le buff
was asked his first question he gave the
seemingly nonsensical response when the
seagulls follow the trawler it's because
they think sardines will be thrown into
the sea thank you very much he then left
the press conference all together
catching his fellow panelists off guard
given his history of plagiarism it might
not come as a surprise to learn that
this quote about seagulls and sardines
does not originate with LaBeouf instead
the quote comes from French football
player Eric Cantona who also confused
people when he gave the same strange
answer during a press conference before
leaving abruptly many of Le Buff's
wildest Antics were actually carried out
as acts of performance art even though
he was the face of all these
performances wasn't the only person
orchestrating them behind the scenes at
some point around 2014 Le buff teamed up
with artists Luke Turner Saudi runco and
the trio was responsible for conceiving
and executing all of his performance art
stunts they collaborated on his I am not
famous anymore red carpet stunt before
taking the same concept A step further
with a piece they called hashtag I am
sorry a similar paper bag was placed
over LaBeouf's head and he installed
himself as an art exhibit in LA's Cohen
Gallery before perform governments
lasted for five days during which time
laboff lived inside the gallery visitors
to the gallery were let into the room
housing Lo buff one at a time while he
sat in Silence the performance took a
dark turn when one visitor allegedly
crossed the line between art and crime
speaking to dazed LaBeouf claimed that a
woman whipped his legs for 10 minutes
and then sexually assaulted him the
incident was corroborated by Turner and
runco LaBeouf claims to have remained in
character for the rest of the
performance even as his girlfriend
visited him after the news of the
disturbing incident reached her and I
think you need a little bit of a touch a
Sprinkle of insanity to be a good artist
as LaBeouf worked to shed the stigma
associated with child actors he became
known as a hardcore method actor in his
adulthood similar to how other prominent
method actors have taken things too far
on occasion LaBeouf pushed many
boundaries while making 2014's Fury in
an interview originally published in
British GQ labus co-star Logan Lerman
revealed that the cuts on the Buff's
face throughout the movie were not
makeup he even caused the wounds right
in front of Lerman without warning with
Lerman saying he takes out a knife and
cuts his face for the whole movie he
kept opening these cuts on his face
that's all real but Le Buff's bodily
transformation for the role didn't end
there he took things even further by
getting a tooth removed LaBeouf told
extra that it wasn't a tough decision to
have a tooth pulled since it helped him
get into character after having trouble
finding a dentist willing to yank out a
healthy tooth LaBeouf told Jimmy Kimmel
so I got it done by some guy in Reseda
next to a Radio Shack Le buff Turner and
runco continued creating performance art
pieces into 2015. one 30-minute piece
titled hashtag introductions became
better known for the one minute long
excerpt just do it which went Mega viral
as a motivational meme that same year
laboff also made hashtag all my movies
the performance lasted for 72 straight
hours the entirety of which was live
streamed the performance involved Le
buff watching every movie he ever made
from his latest man down back to his
first breakfast with Einstein while a
camera recorded his unfiltered reactions
whether they be positive or negative or
even falling asleep both introductions
and all my movies were far less
confrontational incendiary and Boundary
pushing than Le Buffs 2014 performance
art pieces and they provided a bit more
to chew on and analyze artistically as
well it seemed the trio of performance
artists were finding a suitable Groove
for their creative works but LaBeouf
soon pivoted in a New Direction and
wound up in hot water again Le buff made
his feature-length screenwriting debut
in 2019 with honeyboy the year before
the film was made and released LaBeouf
did something with his script that a
Hollywood star should never do he
entered it in a screenplay contest
designed for emerging screenwriters
LaBeouf introduce script for honeyboy
into the page International
screenwriting Awards which is a
competition specifically designed for
Outsiders and newcomers to the film
industry who lack professional
connections honeyboy made it to the
quarterfinals which landed both La buff
and the competition itself in hot water
with the screenwriting Community for
allowing him to compete despite the
outrage LaBeouf did it again with his
next screenplay minor modifications
which has not been produced yet as of
the making of this video he entered the
script in the Sun Valley film festival's
screenplay competition and this time he
won the top prize it is important to
note that the top prize was one thousand
dollars mentoring and meetings with film
industry professionals these benefits
would mean a great deal to actual
emerging screenwriters while they would
mean absolutely nothing to someone as
established and connected as Shia
LaBeouf other than perhaps a boost to
his ego the controversy surrounding
honeyboy were not limited to its
screenplay contest participation alone
the film was a major critical success
and took home prizes from many film
festivals the plot about a child actor
dealing with his abusive father was said
to be based on the Buff's childhood with
LaBeouf playing his own father in the
film she feeling your head full of fear
I don't never do that do I huh I'll pump
you full of strength Le Buff's deeply
personal
autobiographical connection to the story
was a point highlighted in countless
glowing reviews of the film but it was
all a lie after touting the film as an
autobiographical true story for years
the buff admitted to making it all up in
2022. the confession came on the podcast
real ones hosted by John Bernthal
despite painting his father as horrible
and abusive LaBeouf told burnfall my dad
was so loving to me my whole life he was
always there my dad never hit me never
he spanked me once one time and the
story that gets painted in honeyboy is
this dude is abusing his kid all the
time I wronged him Le buff also admitted
to sending his father an altered script
that had all of the abuse taken out in
order to manipulate him into giving his
permission to make the movie about him
and I turned a knob up on certain that
wasn't real wall dating Talia Burnett
better known by her stage name FKA twigs
LaBeouf reportedly subjected her to what
the New York Times called a Relentless
abusive relationship the two met while
filming honeyboy in 2018 and were
together until she built up the courage
to escape the following year FKA twigs
ended up suing LaBeouf and as of the
making of this video the trial has been
delayed to late fall 2023. his alleged
instances of emotional mental sexual and
physical abuse included behavior-like
threatening to crash their car choking
her in her sleep physically and sexually
assaulting her on multiple occasions
intentionally giving her an STD without
her knowledge and more he was
threatening to crash the car unless I
said I loved him and after hearing FKA
Twiggs Story one of Le Buff's exes
Carolyn foe claimed that she had been
through similarly terrible experiences
with the actor Le buff initially denied
the accusations telling the times many
of these allegations are not true but he
later seemed to change his tune on John
bernthal's podcast saying I hurt that
woman I up bad like Crash and
Burn type he also said that by outing
him FKA twigs saved my life and that he
planned to serve as a role model for
principled living moving forward which
remains to be seen one of the most
disturbing facets of FKA Twiggs long
list of allegations against Le buff was
his violent Behavior toward animals
During the period of time that they were
living together LaBeouf began preparing
for his role in the tax collector part
of his preparation involved buying a
real gun which he kept loaded right by
his side of the bed every night FKA
Twiggs said she was so afraid that he
would end up shooting her that she began
to leave little clues for her manager so
they would be able to figure out what
happened if he killed her Beyond her
fears for her own safety FKA twigs also
claimed that lobuff was using this gun
to shoot stray dogs this was something
that she said he did repeatedly and was
proud of as part of his method acting
approach to his role in the tax
collector FKA twigs told Elle that she
confronted him about the dog killing I
said to him that's really bad why are
you doing that and he was like because I
take my art seriously you're not
supporting me in my art this is what I
do I'm in the character if you or
someone you know is dealing with
domestic abuse you can call the National
Domestic Violence Hotline at
1-800-799-7233 you can also find more
information resources and support at
their website
[Music]